on en parlait il y a quelques instants
le groupe ADF vient de s'installer dans
les Yvelines à Manille et amo enfin
vient de s'implanter réellement dans les
Yvelines vu que vous étiez déjà à
Manille les hameaux Laurent Dufourneau
je rappelle vous êtes le directeur des
opérations pour la région
Île-de-France alors ADF en quelques mots
c'est une entreprise spécialisée en
ingénierie et en maintenance
industrielle et vous intervenez dans de
nombreux domaines de très nombreux
domaines aéronautiques spatial énergie
militaire et j'en passe voilà le groupe
fait énormément d'activités alors je
vais simplement les résumer sinon ça
risque d'être long on fait la
l'ingénierie c'est-à-dire qu'on
développe avec nos clients de du début
de leurs besoins jusqu'à la réalisation
l'étude la partie métrologie puisque on
a un la bonne mesure qui fait 140 m²
avec une innovation qui est arrivée fin
de l'année dernière une machine qui est
unique en France qui permet de mesurer
sur des diamètres de 2 mètres dans le
micro donc voyez très précis avec une
tête rotative et et on va continuer le
processus avec notre client sur
l'installation et toute la partie
maintenant c'est industrielle mais vous
êtes le seul en Europe à posséder cette
tête rotatif
rotative avec la superficie du marbre
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer ce
que c'est une tête rotative et qu'est-ce
qui en fait ça sa spécificité la
spécificité c'est que c'est une tête qui
va mesurer directement grâce à une CAO
l'ensemble des points d'une pièce ou
d'un outillage de façon précis pour voir
s'il y a les conforme ou pas conforme
donc grâce à cette tête rotative on va
aller chercher des points très loin dans
la pièce qu'on pouvait pas faire avant
donc c'est ça qui est un peu la
nouveauté il nous fallait un artifice
qu'on appelait un plateau tournant
qu'ils aient tourné la pièce là c'est la
tête qui tourne elle-même voilà un peu
la nouveauté alors vous êtes présent
depuis 20 ans en Île-de-France et vous
avez décidé de vous installer dans les
Yvelines à Magny-les-Hameaux pourquoi
Manille et un mou alors pourquoi parce
que nos comme je disais en introduction
nos principaux clients sont safran sont
à l'Est son Renault qui sont quand même
très implanté sur cinq sur 50 ans
Yvelines et on a aussi nos clients type
d'assaut ou chaîne Nanterre qui sont
accessibles avec le duplex en une
demi-heure vous êtes rapidement
directement chez ses clients là donc
voilà pourquoi et donc vous passez d'un
site de 800 m² à 1600 mètres carrés
pourquoi pourquoi plus grand vous aviez
besoin de plus d'espace pourquoi parce
qu'on est passé d'un atelier de 300 m²
un atelier 1000 m² pour résumer
l'avantage de la télé 8 m² c'est qu'on
va pouvoir réaliser une activité qu'on
n'avait pas dans le livre de France
qu'elle l'intégration c'est-à-dire qu'on
fait on va faire du montage directement
dans notre atelier pour livrer les
machines directement à nos clients là où
on faisait cette cette
activité à l'extérieur de
l'Île-de-France dans notre groupe et
donc le but était aussi de regrouper
toutes vos filiales
on a énormément d'oignons d'innovation
on parle de la réalité virtuelle on
parle de logiciel qui permet
d'accompagner nos clients sur
l'augmentation de production le suivi de
leur production aussi donc voilà ça on
parle beaucoup d'innovation et c'est
quelque chose qui qui nous que les
identifie auprès de nos clients
puisqu'on leur rapporte des innovations
lors de leurs besoins et on est capable
de les accompagner aussi bien sur
l'outillage que du coin ingénierie au
niveau de leurs produits on a on
accompagne actuellement typiquement
Alstom sur l'ascenseur à mobilité
réduite du nouveau TGV par exemple donc
ça c'est nous qui le font la
co-ingénierie avec eux et la fabrication
dans nos ateliers et alors en 15 ans
vous avez triplé votre chiffre
d'affaires d'ici 2025 vous visez les 600
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
votre entreprise on dirait elle connaît
pas la crise elle n'a pas connu la crise
c'est un peu le cas c'est pour ça qu'on
a énormément de besoins en termes de
recrutement
je précisais il y a à peu près il y a un
environ 50 postes ouverts sur
l'Île-de-France
qui passe de mécanicien
électromécanicien d'acheteurs
qualiticiens enfin voilà et j'en passe
et on précise ce n'est que des contrats
c'est des oui alors pourquoi parce que
on est sur sur vraiment de l'expertise
une personne le temps de le former vont
mettre 3 à 6 mois pour être autonome sur
des prestations donc faire un CDD ou un
contrat mission pour nous il y a aucun
intérêt ce qu'on aura formé cette
personne pendant 3 et 6 mois je vois pas
l'intérêt de de faire ce genre de
contrat et donc ce sont des métiers où
vous avez du mal à recruter on a
beaucoup de mal et non vous l'expliquer
c'est ça intéresse peu c'est
la formation est longue c'est que voilà
les gens
ont peut-être trouvé mais on s'est
vraiment des métiers de niche
typiquement parler de métrologie il y a
pas un diplôme de métrologie donc c'est
une formation interne on est obligé de
trouver des gens qui au moins
connaissent la lecture de plan mécanique
mais on peut pas trouver quelqu'un qui a
un diplôme métrologie ça n'existe pas
donc on parle de métrologie les gens la
plupart ne connaissent pas justement ce
métier là donc c'est un peu compliqué à
faire une annonce en précisant un poste
de métrologie et ça parle à très peu de
monde hormis les gens qui ont vu ça dans
des bacs technologiques puisque ils ont
quelques notions de métrologie dans leur
cursus mais c'est tout donc voilà c'est
un exemple donc si on a des potentiels
intéressés parmi nos téléspectateurs ils
peuvent candidater dès aujourd'hui
donc ça il y a pas de souci tous les
tous les les postes sont en ligne donc
voilà qui n'hésitent pas au contraire
ils seront reçus justement dans nos
nouveaux sites de 1600 mètres carrés
bien merci beaucoup Laurent du fourneau
d'avoir répondu à nos questions